auf die oft auch drauf darauf hofft auch
aufs ist servus s kids und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
spielen wir ein spiel was mir in
ziemlichen schrecken einjagen wird
voraussichtlich denn wir spielen heute
den trainings simyo later also den er
trinke simulator dazu muss ich sagen
dass ich unterwasserszenen überhaupt
nicht ab kann die wenn die kamera so
unter wasser ist und das film trotzdem
muss ich irgendwie das ding mal spielen
ich muss es einfach mal ausprobiert wir
schauen uns das jetzt mal an ich habe es
vorher noch nicht gesehen ich spiele das
blind und ich hoffe es ist nicht zu
krass ok starten erst mal sortieren
ich dachte es wären der trink simulator
scheinbar es ist mehr sofia simulator
was noch mal sortieren
das lachen noch vergehen heute diese
musik man denn jetzt bitte keine scheiße
fand nicht ins wasser
leute ich hasse das
was kommt zurück
nein ich hasse das alter junge bei
wegfährt
weißt du bist echt eine pappnase weißt
du dass das war nicht der sinn der sache
als sie dich mit auf diesen segel trip
genommen alterskontrollen was ich mache
hätte sind halt nicht mal wählen warum
steht dass ich so an aufstehen mich so
an mehr trinke ich kann auch schwimmen
euro junge junge junge junge junge im
orbit jetzt bitte das bild lässt sich
firefox aufgehängt ich probier's doch
nichts ist ein traum ich auch weiter
machen was macht den charts bis jetzt
kein hai oder so alter doch einfach mal
wählen kann warum bin ich so
überleben
unter oh ja wahrscheinlich nicht musik
nichts kann glaub ich ist echt gut
nachgestellten so die erschöpfung beim
wassertreten nicht untertauchen nicht
untertauchen
das flugzeug ist unter gewissen oder
ohne wirz gfrerer
was hat spaß gemacht wir nichts getan
warum kann man da überhaupt gewinnen
ich möchte sie wissen ich habe mich
überhaupt nicht eingelesen
auf das oft auch darauf hofft auch
darauf braucht hause
mit erfolg
was war das für ein spiel alter 9
millionen teilnehmer sind bereits
ertrunken 97 millionen war aber immerhin
dass da kein high gekommen man ohne witz
ist es hat sich gut daran
ich habe immer noch nicht ganz
verstanden ich muss mich jetzt erstmal
beruhigen glas gerne leichter bricht die
folge gefallen hat ich weiß nicht was
das war ich hoffe das war nicht so
schlimm für euch wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder bis dahin haut
rein macht gut und ciao